my name is Sridevi Krishnan and I work
as a data engineering manager for Bank
of the West
I live in Pleasanton and work in San
Ramon and an aspiring children's book
author having been in the software
engineering space for close to 15 years
I wanted to diversify my portfolio
having developed interest in children's
book writing I was looking for a program
that would offer a mix of all the
different things that I should be
equipped with to start to embark upon my
new journey and then I learned about
this particular program I fell in love
especially with the design thinking just
that very concept so I I applied and I
am so glad that I got accepted into the
program all the the course material and
the assignments were also so real so
appealing that I would never hesitate to
work past midnight after putting my kids
all the bed and and still with passion
would work on these assignments most
candidates are looking at this program
to you know start run your own business
be an entrepreneur to to innovate this
is your first step and here it is
you're almost there so just apply and
start with your first course
[Music]
you